what is your take on trump going after
elon musk you got a lot of people to go
after why go after elon musk time for
musk you're for musk yeah i think trump
should disappear into the sunset uh
all the circumstances that have happened
i can't
i can understand why he is miffed about
what happened to him through his
presidency he was attacked every day
every day all day i still think the
policies he brought in were worthy and i
still think what biden did to them is
wrong if you look at the just the
southern border and the energy issue and
afghanistan and on and on
i
i believe
he tried to do the right thing during
his presidency but he is a bull in the
china shop
and it would be a good idea if someone
less like that such as desantis desantis
by the way so funny you're saying that
this is this very important that you
took the angle that you took because
trump tweeted about you
i want to say in 16 i don't know the
exact date but he said patrick moore
co-founder of green space cream peace
greenpeace
uh the whole climate crisis is not only
fake news it's fake science there's no
climate crisis there's weather
and climate all around the world and in
fact carbon dioxide is the main building
blocks of life
wow
and then uh who made that quote you or
him i made he quoted me he quoted him so
i put it on the back of my book because
i i wasn't quoting him he was quoting me
that's right
i thought that's fine so he's a fan of
yours apparently and you want him out of
you don't want him to run for president
again i i didn't say that uh if he
decides to sail off in the sunset yes
if i was him that's what i would do but
i am not him and i'm not i don't have
that temperament
uh maybe he does why do you say that's
what he should do if you're and again
you're an advocate it seems because
i think it's too polarized
[Music]
and i think he's part of the reason why
it is and i think he did a good job when
he was in office but he he would have
done a much better job if they hadn't
impeached him twice
and put him through that whole mueller
investigation which was all phony
baloney so you know you look back in
history and you look at the situation
now and i would have said something
different back then probably i would
have said
carry on but
he shouldn't get into these kind of
myths
with elon musk elon musk is pretty good
he's he's he yes he panders to the
climate issue to a certain extent but
who doesn't well that's right what
helped him become the richest man in the
world exactly but you know you know
what's the crazy thing about this here's
where i don't uh understand his strategy
and i tweeted about this couple days ago
people were all upset i can't believe
you did this whose side are you and i
said i'm not i'm not trying to make more
friends i'm just telling you how i
process this because
so you say this about musk
he's the lead today as a republican and
it's not even close i think it's like 46
is him 29 is uh
uh desantis and then i think it drops to
seven percent cruz and i think it's six
percent is pence and nicky he's still
the guy in the republicans so check this
out so you make a comment about a guy
that's got 100 million twitter followers
and you're not on twitter he's on
twitter
rogan a week ago just said he would
never have you on then musk says this
and you go after musk so let's just say
let's let's play this out
let's say trump is the candidate for the
republican side let's say he is let's
say he wins
you think musk is the kind of a guy that
would flip and say oh we have to vote
for trump
you think musk is all of a sudden going
to get behind trump we think muslims
going to remember what he said when he
called him a [ __ ] artist what kind
of a wiring do you think musk has you
think musk is going to sit there and say
well let's get him in there or he's
going to say [ __ ] why are you putting me
in this guy you cornered musk to not
support you
that's why i do that
but you summed up exactly what i'm
thinking if there's like you talk about
this all the time don't create
unnecessary enemies it's a game of
conversion it's a game of math let's say
you're at 48 you want to get the 52 of
the country to support you because
that's how close these elections are no
sense you're creating unnecessary
enemies you're supposed to be building
advocates and building allies and you're
taking arguably two of the most popular
men in america approval ratings
considered elon musk and joe rogan by
the way who are allies within each other
right those guys are in touch and you're
cornering these guys to basically say
he's untouchable yeah it doesn't make
sense to me and this is the problem that
people have for trump it's like make
these guys your allies not your enemies
or at the very least be neutral
let me know
you can understand why trump is bitter
but he is bitter and that doesn't look
good no it's not attractive you don't
when he was saying make america great
again it wasn't from a place of
bitterness it was a from places this is
friends
it was it was from a different place but
but you should read that but you know
what it is here's a question you gotta
ask yourself okay here's a question i
got and i asked this i said and i put
that in the tweet afterwards i said i
said the only way this makes sense is
the following way the only way to go go
back to my tweet it's part two the only
way this makes sense is if
his concern is more to increase
valuation of truth social over him
becoming president
maybe that's his agenda but by the way
let me unpack that in case anybody if in
case there's a one percent chance of
this being true which 99 it's not if it
is
president trump just so you know
the day comes where the world is
celebrating your funeral and and your
service to whatever you did in humanity
somebody that became very successful in
business and media and you were a
controversial figure that became a
president your policies were effective
but you you know people hated you you
had a lot of different things that
happened
no one's gonna care whether you die
being worth three billion dollars ten
billion dollars a hundred million
dollars and i'm willing to say even if
somehow some way you're worth 300
billion dollars that reputation of
business nothing's gonna change
you winning one more time and coming
back and being able to redeem yourself
that's the true legacy and you're
hurting yourself when you do stuff like
this this to me made no sense with so so
i don't know what i'm saying so let's
just say the smack of truth social goes
and he sells it for 20 billion dollars
and he's 38 percent owner he gets you
know 7.6 billion
who gives a [ __ ]
who cares yeah so you so what you got
another 7.6 billion dollars i'm 100
you're basically saying the bigger
challenge is your legacy who gives a
[ __ ] if you have a couple more
real estate in the most competitive
environment new york and the most hey
you you came up and you had all this
stuff always daddy's son you left the
other side to go making in manhattan
your name trump is all over hotels then
you have a reality tv show then you go
out and become a president like who's
who's been able to do that's like saying
you're a trifecta you know like this guy
can dance he can sing you can act yeah
dude you won in business you wanted
media and you won in politics what are
you talking about how many people like
that are there not many what are you
doing so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
you